the jurogan experience so that's one
issue with the death county is that
so many of the people so so let's say
you're and i urge people one of the
things that i've done a couple times on
twitter that always gets an interesting
response is
you can go look at coroner's reports
especially in milwaukee where they put
them all online
of people who've died so you can
actually see the people who have died
of covid and you'll see how sick they
are for the most part
i'm talking about people in their 80s
and 90s who have multiple severe
comorbidities
so in that case it's really hard to tell
did this person die with covet
or from covid you know if my heart is
failing and my kidneys are failing
and i get this thing and i die the next
day
okay i died did i die did i die with
covet or did i die
two weeks before i would have died
anyway and we're counting that as from
coveted or maybe even a year before you
would have died anyway but
the 2.6 co-morbidity factors that's the
average that's right for people that
died of cove
that's correct that's a good way of
saying it
again it's very very hard to distinguish
with and from in these cases of people
who are really sick now sometimes it's
not that way sometimes you can say again
a 50 year old who is relatively healthy
gets coveted they died they died from
covid okay covet killed them we can
agree about that but at the
many of the cases are hard to hard to
understand or not hard to understand but
hard to distinguish
and i'll make one more point about
deaths very very very important point
pcr testing you you you know you
i know i know you know you know what
this is yes you
you know you you look for a sample of
the virus in you know usually it's in
the nose
you multiply it and you
run a cycle where it doubles over and
over and over again and when it gets to
a certain point
uh they actually it's it's actually
incredible technology it's sort of
it's sort of magical but they add a
fluorescent
marker to it and at some point if you
can see the fluorescence it's considered
a positive sample
okay here's the thing a 40 cycle
pcr test means that you are multiplying
the original
any original viral material in that
sample by one trillion times
okay so a single viral particle that you
pick up
becomes one trillion particles
it is very very easy to find virus
in people when you're running a pcr
cycle at that
at that level okay it does not mean
necessarily that they're very sick at
the time it doesn't even mean that they
have active virus in their bodies at the
time they could have a piece of virus
that uh that that the that the original
sample is picking up and multiplying by
40x okay
it's clear by the way when people have a
low threshold let's say 20 times let's
say it only takes 20 cycles that's a
million
multiplications if you're positive at 20
cycles you're pretty sick
if you're positive at 25 cycles you're
probably pretty sick
if you're positive at 30 cycles maybe
not
40 cycles it doesn't really mean
anything it means that you have
you know you have this one bit of virus
in you that they've managed to find
does it mean you're contagious it
probably doesn't mean you're contagious
i don't like that word
i like that word probably well i'm
around grandma
i i don't like to say never
unless i'm sure okay right so when i say
probably
it usually means never but i just don't
like saying i understand
okay when we count
deaths the states have a procedure most
states
they look at positive tests and they
match them with death certificates
okay so let's say you had a positive
test
okay in tomorrow okay and let's say it
was 38 cycles they're not going to tell
you that but it was 38 cycles okay
you are not very sick at all with covid
okay but you're in a registry somewhere
your name's in a registry
a month and a half later you die let's
say you get hit by a car
that will still initially come up as a
positive coveted death
because you had a positive test and you
died within a specific amount of time
after having that test but they don't
distinguish from a violent accident
not not initially now some of the states
are trying to clear this up but let's
say you died of a heart attack joe
okay a heart attack is a potential you
know outcome of covet
you're always going to be on there if
you died of a heart attack so you're
saying that if you have this tiny amount
of covet in your system you never wind
up getting sick
but yet you have a heart attack a couple
weeks later three four weeks later
they will still call that a covid death
one even though you never got sick from
kovacs 100
that doesn't seem smart uh the idea is
to capture
deaths as broadly as possible the idea
is this is a you know
serious illness and we want to know
every possible person who's died from it
we don't do this with any other illness
is it because they don't have the
resources
differentiate between the people that
have died from heart attacks where it's
clear
oh we looked at the person they had a
very small amount of the virus in this
system
four weeks later there's no way they
were sick from that but
is that it's a function of decisions
that have been made along the way so
they could have set
the pcr threshold at lower they could
have said it at 30.
they were aware from almost the
beginning of this issue
that you know you can find a comment
from fauci in july talking about this
okay but and certainly and you know and
certainly they knew well before this
the idea was we want to know
sort of as broadly as possible how many
people have this and then secondarily
we want to define deaths from covid as
broadly as possible and what is the
what is the level set up currently um
different states have different levels
but in most places it's 37 to 40 cycles
which again means that a lot of those
people at the high end
are not sick and they they certainly had
covet at some point
but they probably don't have it anymore
here's here's the other reason to do
this show
if you if you set it really high you're
going to capture people on the way in
just as they're getting sick so if
you're truly afraid of we want to
quarantine everybody
really early then you have to set the
threshold really high so
so that to the extent there's a logic
behind it that's the logic behind it but
it has all these negative side effects
um so there was one other point i want
to make but i
i'll remember it in a second so the
negative side effects would be
that the the they're inflating the
number of people
that not just have it but die from it
because of the fact that they're
making sure that these deaths that get
linked within a certain time period what
is the time period so in some states
it's 30 days in some states it's 60 days
i don't know if it's more than 60
anywhere
um but but the states are sort of
allowed to define it oh
here's okay so there's a negative for
the person who's tested positive because
you then have to isolate yourself you
can't work
you know you're scared um and then
there's this negative for society with
the death counts later right but isn't
that that negative
that you have to isolate yourself and
you can't work that seems very rational
because if you do test like let's say
you're on the way in
you catch it you have a little tiny bit
of it in your system and they're like
you have to isolate you have covet yes
what if that person just went out and
started drinking
got run down the covet multiplies and
then they have a full blown case and
then they start spreading so so that is
look
realistically can that happen sometimes
yes that seems like that would happen a
lot
well it doesn't happen that much because
at 37 you're asymptomatic so you're not
going to know
unless you have some reason to be tested
but isn't there a significant amount of
spread from asymptomatic people so this
is another argument that we
don't there's asymptomatic spread it
looks to be very rare
although you know now fauci is saying
it's not so rare there's pre-symptomatic
spread pre-symptomatic spread appears to
be more real
we need another person other than fauci
that's the one guy
we do like everyone says fauci says like
we have this guy
yes let me let me let me say one more
thing about death count
okay okay back in march and april people
said
kova deaths are being undercounted we
don't we're not doing enough testing
there's all these people dying they're
being called pneumonia deaths it's
probably cobit that was
probably true at the time especially in
new york and new jersey you can look and
you can see the number of
what are called excess deaths more
people dying than you would expect in a
normal year
was higher than the number of cova
deaths okay and a lot of those deaths
were in people who had pneumonia okay so
that
looks like hey we didn't even you know
this is even worse than we thought we're
capturing
uh we're not even capturing everybody
who died okay but that was march and
april
let's talk about what's happening now we
know
the pcr tests are going to capture a lot
of people who aren't sick
anymore and who maybe never were sick we
know
that some of those people are going to
be classified as covet deaths
if they again i'm 88 i
i somehow you know was asymptomatic a
month ago i but i got a positive pcr
test now i die because i'm 88
that's a coveted death okay
what we're seeing now in the united
states and certainly in
in europe we don't have data as good in
the us from the last couple weeks but we
have some pretty good data from europe
and the uk
is that the number of cova deaths when
you add it to the number of non-cova
deaths
is not as high as the overall number of
deaths you would expect
so what does that tell you that tells
you that some
non-cova deaths are probably being
classified as covades these days so back
in march and april
there were more people dying than you
would have thought based on the number
of covadas
now there are fewer people overall dying
than you would think
based on the number of cover deaths and
i gotta add one more thing i know this
gets complicated
but it's worth it's worth thinking about
we also know that a significant number
of people are dying from lockdown
okay there and and and the number one
way you can look at that is overdose
okay overdose deaths in this country
have all you know they've been terrible
for years
this year it looks like they're off the
charts so
if 20 or 30 000 people and that's
probably
a reasonable estimate 20 or 30 000 extra
people are dying
this year from overdose alone
that's that should push up the number of
overall deaths
and yet when you and then if you'd add
the cova deaths it should be even higher
when you put these three things together
right now you're getting fewer deaths
than you would expect
again what i'm trying to say is i know
that this math can sort of seem
complicated and the stacking can seem
complicated
but right now it looks like a
significant number of deaths that are
being classified as covid
would have occurred anyway and are just
sort of being shifted into the covet
pile and that was not so true
a few months ago so when you see 3 000
people died today of covid
until we get the true mortality figures
for this year for for november and
december
we're not going to know if that's really
true catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience